of lack of the vision that is I give one
example many years ago probably more
than 30 will something like 30 to 33
professor Polanski wrote absolutely
fantastic article about question of
silence of roshan roshan ability in time
of the union of Lublin I mean this
Lublin union of Lublin was coming long
time everybody uses that is so to speak
crown program and Lithuania port again
said somehow wine in that period of time
there is no good preparation on the side
of of Ukrainians to size the moment and
to recreate kayvyun rush it was very
powerful question question which until
today still brings our discussion I
Evancho had quite a few see interesting
things very recently to say about it but
but honestly isn't that a question also
to the polish historians I mean what
what was the polish vision okay
Ukrainians didn't do it and of course we
can suggest why but my polls didn't have
any vision they were just marching kind
of in enlarging the crown with a
particular game for themselves I mean
this idea of getting land moving there
it's not so to such as simple and true
idea so what will save you what will say
things a vision second thing second
example all's we fighting very much for
establishing a system in which citizen
has a control over the legislative
process true but that was connected with
destruction or portal
in a very strong way of the aristocracy
they didn't push that on territories of
Ukraine they accepted Ukraine s
oppressive social structure there was
very similar to the one on Chrome
territories by doing so they just do
themselves once no not article clear
vision of of the future and refused or
couldn't see in Cossacks equal to them
people the one may say that not only
starting up is that because that is not
true but just cause acts but
professional Cossacks will establish
cause lakhs where unquestionably richer
or more experienced people than majority
of Polish nobility in Missouri and
surely richer still polish parliament as
whole polish local councils never sells
that simple fact that people similar to
them inside of Z own territories he
lived could be the best allies in the
political fight which was going every
day every week every month every year
and ending fight between the three
proverbial powers monarchy aristocracy
and democracy and that far end and if I
say the lack of Polish vision here is
enormously surprising and and one as I
say head
big make question what would the Polish
vision of today be better in the back